the reason i was i was kept bothering
you kept bothering to have this
conversation is i'm really worried about
the next couple of months no kidding
and out if there's anybody in this world
that could help alleviate
my worry by by at least
walking along with me through this worry
of
mine it's you do you think we're headed
towards
some kind of civil war some kind of
division that explodes beyond just stuff
on twitter
but something that's really destruct
destructive
to the fabric of our society well i i
believe we're in a revolution
as you know i've called it the no name
revolution or n squared revolution i've
been talking about it for years
i don't think i think waiting for this
to be called a civil war is not smart
only history we'll call it such fine but
i think that the problem is is that
you're encountering things that you've
never seen
trying to fit them into things that you
already know right
and but history repeats itself
yes ish
you don't see lessons from history and i
do we see today
but i don't see it repeating itself you
know the the violent
famous quote is that it rhymes it rhymes
i mean
the thing i guess i'm speaking to is
violence
and we're in there the abstraction of
violence
imagine you were coding up violence as
an abstract class
okay thank you for speaking to the
audience
trying to lose these people come with me
go on i don't know i i i've dealt with
your audience
and your audience contains the smartest
people around yeah
i guarantee you if i say some stuff uh
first of all any wrong thing that i'll
say they're gonna detail so that'll be a
little bit of catnip to bring in the
smart people
but they'll also digest it for each
other it's one of the great lessons of
long-form podcasting if you don't
if you don't waste all your time
explaining things that's the job of the
audience to do amongst
themselves they're happy doing the work
and those who aren't
they leave isn't that great they'll
leave the people who don't want to
struggle will leave
you can get rid of them i think that the
point is
you you would want to say violence is
defined relative to a context so
let's call it meta-violence so that we
don't get into the
the problem we already have a term for
physical violence right so we have meta
violence
and physical violence i would say that
physical violence is subclassed from
meta violence meta violence is the
disruption of
a system it's sort of you know it's a
you know if we for example if a cell
dies you can die through
apoptosis or necrosis apoptosis is
controlled
programmed cell death uh necrosis is
just like
okay this didn't work that was a violent
disruption of the system
and this meta class is presumed in the
documentation
is it all negative no what are you
talking about
so this is part of the problem in the
madness of our age
right which is if you if you open up a
drawer
in your in your cabinet right
in your kitchen and you see knives
spoons and forks
do you have a sense that the spoons are
good utensils and the knives or forks or
bad utensils because they're mean
i mean like if you start thinking in
these terms yeah
that knife is there to do violence
that's violence you want done
right when i cut a mango i'm doing
violence to the mango
the mango expects that i will do
violence to it because otherwise it
i won't be able to get the the meat and
it won't
get its seed um spread somewhere else
so in part violence is absolutely part
of our story
so okay so there's this meta-violence
class
yeah and what's so the meta-violence
class is already
you know it's a multiple inheritance
pattern whatever's going on right now
inherits from meta violence
no but there's there's certain
subclasses that
allow evil to emerge so what
what i'm specifically worried about is
that
what's on your mind like what's really
going on okay
i i worry that um amidst the chaos
of we have these protests or
the chaos that could be created by
the feeling that the election does not
represent
the the voice of the people like saying
that
whoever gets quote unquote wins the
election according to
the some kind of reporting of the
numbers that come out
that's not going to represent what
people
actually who people actually want to be
the leader
like something in that narrative will
create so much division
that people will resort to literal
violence like protests that really
that the united states loses its united
aspect and
because of that because of that chaos
and tension
evil evil people evil forces that my
definition of
evil is you know just cruel human beings
use that moment to attain power the kind
of power
that is ultimately goes against the
ideal
of the united states that could be
donald trump that could be
another human being it doesn't really
matter the my
my worry is that love doesn't win out in
this
the unity doesn't went out in this and i
feel like
you and i have responsibility
no small yeah i know and so how do we
let
love win in this moment of
we're going to potentially you're going
to have to become a fighter
and you have to you have to throw some
serious punches if that's what you want
you have to be muhammad ali here because
the moment you start criticizing
anything
yeah people you have to be a masterful
communicator because that's why you're
here
look lex in part
your decency is allowing you to do
things that you couldn't otherwise do i
saw that you had michael malus
on your podcast yeah now michael malus
is i think of somebody who at his best
is extremely shrewd and insightful yes
he's also got this trolling game which
he's quite open about and you talk to
him about it which i can't stand
and that's this is the idea oh grandpa
doesn't get the internet well i'm
grandpa i don't get the internet i don't
love the trolling
yeah there are trolls of the past
who were incredibly good i don't see any
of the
modern trolls as being that kind of
genius level trolling the people who
deserve
it in the way that they deserve it you
know right now what i see is
that anything that stands up gets cut
down yeah you know it's like anything
earnest
you have to turn into cynicism and a
meme and it's this idea that the people
who believe that the world is chaos and
has no point
are constantly trying to let you know
don't try to use the internet
for meaning for decency for goodness
because we are going to find out that
that's all sanctimonious hypocrisy
and we will we will make you suffer so
i do think that there's a lot of
sanctimonious hypocrisy in the world
some of it mine
some of it yours but we all have it
and the trolls somewhat remove that but
it's not a judicious
kind constructive compassion a caring
version most of the time and a lot of
those trolls
and i i have this feeling about michael
malus i don't know whether it's right
that there's somebody who deeply cares
and loves beneath it
and that that's motivating some of the
trolling behavior and you and i don't
seem to be doing that i don't see you as
almost ever trolling yeah you and i are
i
i'm very much against trolling i'm very
much against trolling it doesn't mean
that in selective
you know i'm not even it's not even true
like
everything we say we say like i'm
forward i'm against it
this isn't my native language i speak
nuance i don't speak this internet [ __ ]
and the more i have to communicate
through internet [ __ ]
right i almost never take a tweet
seriously if it contains the
the letters lmao lol rtfl
you know fol there's a interesting
effect where people say stuff and then
finish with lol
you put it beautifully that it indicates
to me that this is a person
we've talked about like why i wear this
stupid suit yeah it's like
this is anti this is to fight the lol at
the end of sentences
is take it's like stand out for the
words you're saying
yeah don't finish stuff with lol
removing completely the responsibility
of the content of the sentence that
preceded it
yeah also choosing the outfit that
worked both for men in black and the
blues brothers
not a terrible choice okay but getting
back
look lex we're not in a position to do
this
you need to be seated in a different
chair
your chair is the wrong chair you're in
the wrong chair
it's been so long all right i want to
talk about you
and joe biden
joe biden was a 29 year old guy with
nothing particular going on
so far as i can tell okay
i know people as impressive at age 29 as
joe biden
you know 12 rows back three three deep
doesn't matter
a huge number of people none of them my
age can get to where he got
like we're all morons
anytime somebody takes out like if you
found eddie van halen in a guitar shop
you'd be angry what is this guy doing
repairing guitars then somebody said
maybe he loves to repair guitars
i mean what is your piano russian piano
tuna doing what is my russian piano
that was the whole point of that story
which is
what is it that happened in that life
that converted somebody and i find this
for example with
russian doctors who are you know
technicians in offices now
there's a huge amount of talent in the
world that's not
sitting in its proper seat yeah
and quite honestly i've gotten to the
point where my feeling is we've got to
take the seats
right maybe we don't sit in them maybe
the idea is that we take the seats and
we put some smart
gen z person in the seat and say look
no chanting i don't want to hear you say
no justice no peace
if there aren't verbs if if it rhymes
it's wrong
like i used to have this thing if it
rhymes things that rhyme are more true
but like in general if something starts
out one two three four i don't wanna
hear what the rest of your sentences
you